aber am schluss ein interesse das ist
randvoll story 2 pfund gut 1
mit der regulierung der politik regula
ruetz präsidentin der grünen partei der
schweiz ist 57 jahre alt lebt mit ihrem
partner in bern
sie hat geschichte studiert und mit dem
lizentiat abgeschlossen
heute arbeitet sie hauptberuflich in der
politik regula ruetz ist seit 2011 im
nationalrat fritz in der friends serie
der bagger unterwegs grünen c6000
politik und brauchen keine dürfen und
mit blick auf seine mitbürger geht weit
weg von dem trubel hier und da mit blick
auf die unglaublich schöne landschaften
und mit dem körper den höchsten klasse
setzte namen für eine gute zukunft für
die jungen hüpfer auf die straße für
besseren klimaschutz
wenn man das abo zu pflügen versteht
sich ein kreis auto saßen fast nur
vegetarisch ist dass der lebensstil wo
mir bis heute die übernahme ist auch der
grüne gott es ist da war für mich stimmt
und es ist unglaublich für
lebensqualität damit verbunden
es gibt viele andere möglichkeiten für
das mit der telekom kunden einfach
verantwortungsübernahme für die zukunft
aber ich aus eigener erfahrung weiß alex
frei und unbelastet vorfinden
materielle druck was geht und was nicht
alles so politik überhaupt sondern das
ideal propagieren ist ganz wichtig aber
wichtig ist dass politik die
rahmenbedingungen setzt damit sie das
grün machen ohne dass sie das problem
nach er zum beispiel mit dem die rote
mit unfairer handelsbeziehungen wurde zu
führen er sitzt im amazonas mal die
pläne der politik hat die ganz ganz
wichtig so lässt sie muss wirklich die
landespartei ausgestaltet dass manche
unterschiede gerade und wie es bei
glücklich das ist ziel von der politik
rahmenbedingungen gesetzt damit menschen
sich ein glück also das ist nachhaltige
also das ist ja der mündige bürger die
mündige bürgerin wofür sich selber aber
oft gemeinschaft mithilft die bilder gut
rappen swizz beatz für und das geht ganz
vielen privaten das ist wichtig aber am
schlossplatz auf politiker was es einem
möglich dass mir das mal als ziel
gesetzt aber wenn mit maßnahmen sind es
oft verbot zur regulierung schranke zum
schutz vor den wald zum schutz vor
nachkommende generationen ist auch
fördervereine zu stark steigen
verantwortung und freiheit setzt ford
einzelne bürgerinnen es braucht aber
beides über auch das buch wirklich
dilitronics hat deutlich auf die straße
raus tragen sie beim notwendigkeit ihn
das möglichst innerhalb von weniger
jahre aus der abhängigkeit von öl gas
und kohle die befreiende sicher groß
für anträge die wirtschaft gesellschaft
sie wüssten nicht wie ihr und darum
danke ist muss politik und die einzelne
verantwortungsvolle menschen müssen sich
die tanz spielen
und darum brauche politik wurde auf der
nächsten wahlen vorwärts macht mit einer
spende aus dem analogen zukunft vor
thema dieses jahres großes drama
als junge frau monika aber sie und wenn
die augen geschlossen
völlig vernünftig noch akzeptiert werden
was würden sie sagen das ist die
schlechteste eigenschaft von mensch
wir sind aber zu kurzfristig dank
wirklich nur vor der haustür stattfindet
und mooren und lockte die messe jetzt
wollen wir der globalisierten wirtschaft
habe man feststellen dass die
natürlichen lebensgrundlagen und immer
mehr aufbruch ziehen muss man mit
prächtiger verdanken sie davon
danke
das ganze muss man das ganze
wirtschaftssystem letztlich umkrempeln
das heißt ruft ein wirtschaft ohne
wachstum sogar würde dieser liga wird es
sei es durch die wirtschaftszone
wachstumszwang also es gibt immer sachen
wo gerade wachsen gespielt bevölkerung
wird älter
das heißt ganz gesundheitsbereich und
die pflegeberufe zu komplex ist wird
nicht unterstützt werden wenn sie älter
sind wenn sie hier auf nötig aber es
gibt die ganze wirtschaft dass wir mit
vernünftigen regelungen auf die politik
es gerichtlich finden vor der
wirtschaftlichen entwicklung aber nicht
durch feuchte vor der lebensgrundlage
für die heutige generation mit 20 und 40
jahren noch selber wird so wollen
mitentscheiden wie es mich nicht
natur für sie eigentlich ein bad im see
oder ist das was letztlich nur unter
mensch und zukünftige generationen
wie ist das denn sie hätten halt immer
parat um 90 stellen die natur und
natürlich auch selber tony montana hat
dann aber umgekehrt geht es nicht und
mich stellt er fest dass man die
natürliche grenze überschritten wo
regenerierbar keita würden möglich also
dass sagt natur wird es so gewollt dass
man sich an nutzer und darum ist für
mich klar dass ich im eigenen interesse
von den 90 die sie nachhaltig lage und
das jahr nicht überstrapazieren
das mit micky maus voraussetzung für die
das land gespendet und wie es mit der
vorstellung ihre politik sozialer die
impressionen mit natürlich ein
unglaublicher druck geht für
kommerzielle jährige und für profis das
erhöhte risiko tierfabriken akzeptiert
frau andere länder unter hier wirklich
billigfleisch report die ihre sache
standlicht eine verantwortung für das
tier allein stemmen und wird mit den
letzten jahren lady sämtliche vorschläge
für mädchen und für mehr spektakel auf
importierte nahrungsmittel
ich glaube sich zwar wie sieht es mit
dem hintergrund ist wirklich nachhaltige
spielregeln
präventiv antibiotika setzte das heißt
sich linie stellen sie aber nicht in
eine steilrinne wie das in deutschland
wird möglich ist auch die türe wird aber
immer dafür alles ist von nase bis zum
schwanz denn hat man natürlich mehr
zahlte für gute produkt und für die
grünen setzen sich für natur und
umweltschutz oder globale verantwortung
für digitale jährige schlechter
gerechtigkeit gibt es irgendeinen war
das alles zusammen so dass sie die weite
von der europäischen aufklärung der
menschen ganz klar ist welche
grundrechte als mündige bürgerinnen und
bürger in seine verantwortung sagte sie
also wird das mit zusammen für die bahn
gemacht wie immer gemeinsam gut heilbar
und das bild von den fünf vorstände
greifen die selbstverantwortung bekommt
man mit menschlichen solidarität
zwischen manche solidarität ist ganz
starkes fundament vor der bühne wurden
was ist wichtigste wenn sie auf ihre
politische karriere zurück legen was sie
klärten über politik funktioniert
politik und als junge frau hergefahren
war wirklich sehr radikale konsequenz
akzeptieren dass manche wirklich
vielfältig sie und fünf blieben also
sind nicht alle aber im schlussspurt
darum machen wir müssen wir sagen wir
die spieler los angeles ist möglich dass
mit wirtschaft weiter entwickelt ist
freiheit wächst mit plötzlich schrumpft
weil man ja nur noch krise eine private
zum beispiel lange überhitzter welt
abrufbar und liegt damit müssen wieder
letzten rang eins in antwort auf frage
nach dem sinn von lara wieder definitiv
ist ständiges wurde glaubt dass ihn vom
leben wie es der galaxie
das ist auch eine mensch auf dem
planeten aber gut geht und zwar nicht
nur heute sondern neu den akten
allen menschen und groß in grenzen der
solidarität
klar ist bis jede menschliche würde
unser recht egal wo egal wann läuft und
ich glaube ich - bitten dann aber dann
zielorientierter wenn es schwierig ist
klar dass wir für das landesgesetz zum
beispiel sehr gut wird er mit einer
braunen der walter in brasilien
miteinander zurückkommt
hier ist für die grünen im global denken
lokal handeln
man kann ja jetzt gerade drei die mit
dem nur großen präsident vor die
grünliberalen und wir müssen wie das
zusammenpasst klimaschutz und
kapitalismus und was fußball mit politik
zu ändern